welcome to deconstructing chatbots I am
priyanka rec area and in this episode we
will dissect the architecture of
chatbots to better understand the
building blocks in the last episode we
introduced dialogue flow which is an
empty one tool powered by natural
language understanding to facilitate
rich and natural conversations today
let's look at a high-level architecture
dialogue flow sits in the middle of the
stack a user can interface with it we
are all the common channels including
text websites apps messengers and smart
voice devices like google home dialog
flow handles the job of translating
natural language into machine readable
data using machine learning model
trained by your examples once it
identifies what the users talking about
it can hand this data to your back end
where you can use it to make stuff
happen at the back end you can fulfill
the request by integrating with your
other services databases or even
third-party tools like your CRM now
let's dig one layer deeper into the
dialogue flow piece itself we first
create an agent within dialogue flow
agent is basically your entire chat bot
application the experience of collecting
what the users saying mapping it to an
intent taking an action on it and then
providing the user with a response and
in your agent this all starts with the
trigger event called utterance this is
how our users invoke the chat bot so if
I say hey google play some music the
whole sentence is utterance while the
phrase hey Google is the trigger let's
take another example hey Google Talk -
smart scheduler the phrase talk - smart
scheduler is the invocation phrase for
our chat bot and smart scheduler here is
the invocation name once the bot is
activated and has collected the user
utterance we
need to understand what the users intent
is why do they want to talk to our body
so when you say I want to set an
appointment set appointment here is the
intent or if you ask what are your hours
of operation then hours of operation is
the intent to control all this you
provide dialogue flow with different
examples of users intent like set an
appointment hours of operation and
others dialogue flow then trains a
machine learning model with many more
similar phrases and finally Maps the
users phrase to the right intent this
process is called intent matching now
that we know our users intent we need to
know what to do to give them a response
for that you configure actions and
parameters to define the variables you
want to collect and store let's look at
an example set an appointment for 5:00
a.m. tomorrow when a user says that 5:00
a.m. and tomorrow are two critical
pieces of information in that statement
that we would actually need to book an
appointment those variables are defined
as entities dialogue flow offers
different types of entities and we will
cover those in detail in an upcoming
episode once we have the variables we
may use them to provide a static
response to the user or in most cases we
may want to send the variable to our
back-end take some action on it and then
provide a user with a dynamic response
we will look at that in a second okay to
summarize an intent includes training
phrases actions and parameters and a
response depending on what services your
bot offers you might typically have from
few to thousands of intents they could
also be in different languages while we
are looking at the architecture it's
worth mentioning context context is the
method for your chat bot to store and
access variables so it can exchange
information from one intent to another
in a conversation we will have more
information on context in an upcoming
episode fulfillment is the last piece in
the puzzle
it's the code that you write to
interface with the back-end services to
respond to a dynamic request we will
play with this a lot more soon but for
now note that dialogue flow has inbuilt
integration with Google cloud functions
to interface with your back-end and you
can also provide an other HTTP endpoint
and dialogue flow we'll just connect to
it all right so today we looked at a
simple high-level architecture of
setting up an agent within dialogue flow
and learnt about intense entities
context and fulfillment at a high level
next we are going to go hands-on and
build a simple appointment scheduler
chat bot if that sounds exciting to you
join me in the next episode of
deconstructing chat BOTS
[Music]